soir jean-claude beaujour merci de ceux
avec nous alors fait divines où l'on
craint un rebond de l'épidémie comme les
autorités sanitaires elles ont affirmé
vous le craignez aujourd'hui c'est un
vrai risque que l'on a aux états unis
c'est vrai que là la fête du
thanksgiving est l'une des fêtes les
plus célébrées aux etats unis c'est un
grand moment de ce côté de l'atlantique
les uns et les autres se retrouvent en
famille alors cette année j'ai constaté
que les uns et les autres avaient aussi
fait preuve de prudence beaucoup de mes
amis m'ont dit nous serons à 2 ou à 3
donc beaucoup de prudence
il sent que les principaux messages
notamment aussi ceux venus de la
communauté internationale sur la manière
de traiter le coc vide est porté porté
leurs fruits
mais malgré tout on peut redouter que
des rassemblements familiaux
surtout lorsqu'on a parfois de très
grandes familles puissent d'être des
kloster pour le court navires us des
rassemblements familiaux on vous dit ya
eu la prudence mais tout de même au
moins un million cent mille personnes
ont pris l'avion dans la seule journée
qui a précédé la fête de thanksgiving
jeudi dernier c'est un nombre record
depuis le début de la pandémie est ce
qu'il aurait fallu peut-être les
empêcher les autorités auraient dû
prendre des mesures nécessaires comme le
fait d'ailleurs emmanuel macron il a
parlé d' empêcher les personnes d'aidé
afin d'essayer de les dissuader d'aller
à l'étranger faire du ski est ce que les
autorités auraient dû faire ça aux états
unis selon vous à leur peau pour
répondre à votre question je préciserai
simplement que c'est un million sur 350
millions d'habitants aux états unis
voyez finalement c'est très marginal en
sachant que ce chiffre habituellement à
cette période de l'année est quasiment
dix fois plus important c'est vraiment
une très grande fête c'est la fête la
plus importante de ce côté de
l'atlantique
est ce qu'il aurait fallu empêcher les
populations de se déplacer savais qu'ici
aux états unis a été bien précisées par
un certain nombre de responsables
politiques qu'ils ne devaient pas y
avoir qu'il n'allait pas y avoir de
confinement généralisée autoritaire un
peu comme à la chinoise oublier à la
française
choix politiques qu'il faut respecter
est ce qu'il aurait fallu faire
autrement mais ça seul l'avenir nous le
dira si effectivement le nombre de
l'explosion du nombre de coureurs virus
est plus important que ce que il aurait
pu que les les chiffres en tendance
exponentielle n'aurait pu le laisser
prévoir alors la question c'est toujours
la même comment va tenir l'hôpital est
ce que l'hôpital aux états unis d'une
manière générale a alors gagné 50 états
ont le sait mais l'hôpital va-t-il
pouvoir faire face à cette éventuelle
flambée on nous annonce alors il y as
que l'hôpital va faire face va pouvoir
faire face et puis surtout les moyens
qui vont être déployés n'oublions pas
qu'ici même s'il y a des hôpitaux
publics il y à de l'aide qui est
apportée par aux plus démunis il ne faut
pas oublier que le coûts hospitaliers
sans commune mesure en tout cas celui
qui facturés aux patients est sans
commune mesure avec ce qui se pratique
en france où et d'une manière générale
en europe ce qui veut dire que cette
situation sanitaire risque de laisser
sur le carreau un certain nombre de
familles qui pourront peu c'est ont
jamais vendre leur maison leur action
vendre un peu de leur patrimoine pour
pouvoir essayer de survivre à ce
patrimoine
cette crise sanitaire donc on voit bien
une situation hospitalière que nous
connaissons mais aussi une situation
humaine une situation de crise
économique pour un certain nombre
d'américains dont on sait bien que
certains ont perdu durablement leur
emploi alors effectivement le futur
secrétaire au trésor a affirmé ce soir
la crise économique actuelle est une
tragédie pour de nombreux américains
ça veut dire que joe biden devait
certainement récupérer un pays
totalement à reconstruire ça va être
très compliqué pour le nouveau président
des états unis
alors j'ai presque envie de vous dire le
la malchance pour l'amérique mais et la
malchance pour joe biden c'est qu'on a
le sentiment qu'il rejoue 2008
souvenez-vous que lorsqu'il est arrivé
aux responsabilités avec barack obama il
y avait la crise économique et le
gouvernent le pouvoir du mouvement avait
du très rapidement perdre de transition
prendre des mesures l'appareil joe biden
n'a pas le temps d'attendre le vin le
vin dès le 20 janvier il est obligé de
mettre en place un certain nombre de
mesures pour limiter ce qui s'annonce
comme une catastrophe épouvantable parce
que vous savez que aux états unis
certains nombre d'emplois dépendent de
l'activité véritablement réel réel au
quotidien ce sont toutes ces personnes
qui sont chauffeurs de taxi qui sont qui
travaillent dans les hôtels qui
aujourd'hui sont sans emploi et donc
qu'ils sont privés de 80 90 % de leurs
revenus
même si ici ou là des aides peuvent être
apportées elles sont sans commune mesure
ici il n'est pas question de rester chez
soi et de recevoir 70 % de sa
rémunération
donc vous imaginez très bien que la
situation est extrêmement difficile sur
le plan humain l'équipe de transition
l'a déjà compris c'est d'ailleurs pour
cette raison qu'elle s'est tout de suite
mise au travail sans même attendre la
reconnaissance de l'élection en tout cas
d'avoir gagné l'élection par par donald
trump elle s'est mise au travail parce
qu'elle sait qu'elle n'a pas le temps
d'attendre dès le 20 janvier elle devra
prendre un certain nombre de décisions
drastiques alors elle a peut-être bien
fait parce que donald trump tu n'es pas
vraiment décidé à reconnaître la
victoire de joe biden
joe biden qui a été déclaré victorieux
dans les tacles et notamment de la
résonance est certifié pourtant donald
trump continue d'affirmer qu'il ne
changera pas d'avis sur ces accusations
sans preuve de fraude électorale
on a du mal de plus en plus peut-être à
comprendre ce que souhaite faire donald
trump
vous savez en tant qu'avocat je dis
souvent que un justiciable a le droit de
prétendre avoir le droit deux donc c'est
le président des états unis qui est
encore donald trump a parfaitement le
droit de contester une chose est
certaine c'est qu'il y à des
institutions qui fonctionnent qui ont
montré qu'elles fonctionnaient donc les
recours il peut exercer ses recours
jusqu'au 8 décembre c'est à dire qu'il a
encore une semaine pour pouvoir purger
pour que ces recours soit purgée à
partir du 8 décembre dès le 14 décembre
il y aura la réunion des grands
électeurs et à partir de ce moment là je
crains qu'il ne puisse plus faire grand
chose
j'ai eu en main la décision de la cour
suprême de pennsylvanie
je peux vous dire qu'elle est sans appel
ou la cour reconnaît qu'il n'ya pas de
manoeuvres de nature à pouvoir et
valider les les résultats en
pennsylvanie alors même je vous le
rappelle qu'en pennsylvanie
il y avait pas moins de vingt grands
électeurs en jeu si la pennsylvanie
les recours ont été rejetés en
pennsylvanie en arizona ça sera ça sera
le cas je crains que ce ne soit que des
déclarations mais malheureusement qu'il
ne rencontre pas ceci qu'on soit pour ou
contre donald trump il s'agit là d'une
réflexion purement juridique
je crois que ce soit goy juridiquement
désormais sans issue alors ordonné à
leurs hommes qu'ils essayent quand même
un petit peu tous les recours un dernier
événement en date la cour suprême qui a
examiné hier la décision du président
sortant d'exclure il sans papiers du
recensement de la population
cette dernière requête de donald trump à
la cour suprême qu'elle pourrait en été
les conséquences
vous savez c'est celle là encore la
quelle que soit la décision de la cour
suprême ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est qu'un juge est à paris tu as
regardera si la décision qui a été prise
a un impact électoral politique de
nature à inverser les résultats dans
l'état concerné imaginez qu'on parle de
la pennsylvanie est ce que cette
décision peut avoir pour conséquence des
versets les résultats en pennsylvanie il
faut regarder là au cas par cas
je crains que ça ne puisse pas être le
cas et donc malheureusement que ça ne
changera en quoi qu'il en soit que les
résultats généraux état par état ne
seront pas complètement changé et donc
le résultat en nombre de grands
électeurs et quasiment qu'on se
consolider à moins de 15 jours
désormais de la réunion des grands
électeurs merci merci jean claude
beaujour d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur un défense pour parler de la
situation conclut qu vide aux états unis
mais aussi la situation en politique
merci à vous merci à vous